-The President and his goons
have been threatening everyone
from sitting Congressmen
to ambassadors
as new evidence emerges
in his impeachment trial.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm no lawyer,
but I'm pretty sure
that when suspects
go on trial for crimes
they try not to commit
more crimes.
Donald Trump, however, is
a different sort of criminal.
For Trump, crimes are kind of
like Lay's potato chips --
betcha can't do just one.
But, hey, you got to at least
give Trump points
for commitment.
One crime isn't enough for him.
He's always got to do
like five at once.
He's like a guy
who steals a camcorder,
sneaks into a movie theater
without paying,
illegally records and sells
the bootleg DVD on the street,
gets arrested,
busts out of jail,
and then holds a screening
of the movie
in a house he broke into.
For example, after Democrats,
led by Congressman Adam Schiff,
completed their arguments
in the Senate impeachment trial
last week,
Trump decided
to threaten Schiff,
who, of course, is also one of
the prosecutors in the trial.
First, here's a brief excerpt of
Schiff's detailed oral argument
in which he laid out the case
for removing Trump from office.
-Can any of us
really have the confidence
that Donald Trump
will put his personal interests
ahead of the national interests?
You know you can't count on him
to do that.
That's the sad truth.
You know you can't count on him
to do that.
And you know you can't trust
this president
to do what's right
for this country.
You can trust he will do
what's right for Donald Trump.
He'll do it now.
He's done it before.
He'll do it for
the next several months.
He'll do it in the election
if he's allowed to.
-It's true. Donald Trump has
never done anything in his life
that didn't benefit him
personally.
I'm pretty sure when he placed
his hand on the Bible
to take the oath of office
he slipped Chief Justice
John Roberts a $20 bill.
"There's more
where that came from
'cause I'm definitely
going to get impeached."
And that's why Schiff's
oral argument was so important.
He laid out in detail
how our Constitution
set up the presidency
as a public trust
and that Trump had repeatedly
violated that trust.
And Trump
clearly saw Schiff's speech,
and he decided to menace Schiff
on Twitter on Sunday.
-"Shifty Adam Schiff
is a corrupt politician
and probably a very sick man.
He has not paid the price yet
for what he has done
to our country."
-Okay, first of all, what do you
mean he hasn't paid the price?
Almost everything Trump says
sounds like a deleted scene
from "The Irishman."
Just kidding.
There were no deleted scenes
from "The Irishman."
Also, he hasn't paid a price?
No one has had a more charmed,
consequence-free life
than Donald Trump.
He's like Mr. Magoo
driving off a cliff
and then gently floating
down to the ground
because he accidentally
opened his umbrella.
Except Mr. Magoo would actually
know how to close an umbrella.
[ Laughter ]
Now, it seems like Trump was
probably lashing out at Schiff
after Schiff cited
a report from CBS
claiming that Trump had warned
Senate Republicans,
who are also supposed to be
impartial jurors in the trial,
not to cross him.
Here's the CBS report
and then Schiff's comments
citing that report.
-One Trump confidant
tells CBS News
that GOP senators
had been warned --
"Vote against the President, and
your head will be on a pike."
-CBS News reported last night
that a Trump confidant said
that GOP senators were warned,
"Vote against your president --
Vote against the President,
and your head
will be on a pike."
Now, I don't know
if that's true.
-I'm gonna take a wild guess
and say it's definitely true.
Although, I will say
the only thing that makes me
doubt this story
is the fact that Trump probably
has no idea what a pike is.
The only pike he's familiar with
is the New Jersey Turnpike.
"I'm gonna put your head on
a pike. Exit 15 by Secaucus.
Then me and my friends are
gonna go hit the mall!"
Then after Schiff
made that comment,
GOP senators feigned shock
that he would suggest
they might be beholden
to a president
who has routinely threatened
anyone who crosses him.
Senator John Barrasso said,
"He has basically offended
every Republican senator
in there tonight."
Senator Susan Collins said,
"I know of no Republican senator
who has been threatened
in any way
by anyone
in the administration."
And Senator Lisa Murkowski said,
"I thought he was doing fine
with moral courage until
he got to the head on a pike.
That's where he lost me."
Oh, is that where he lost you?
"I was gonna vote
to convict Trump,
but then Schiff implied
he was a bully,
and that is where
I draw the line.
What's next? Is Schiff gonna
claim Trump's a golfer
who stands like a mama bear
scaring away a predator?"
I mean, let's remember.
This is a guy who fights with
or attacks literally anyone
who crosses him,
including Republicans,
Gold Star families,
and even his closest friends
and allies
if they even so much
as question him in public.
Trump has done this repeatedly.
He went after former
GOP congressman Mark Sanford
and endorsed
Sanford's primary opponent
just because Sanford
criticized him on TV.
And Trump
even brought up the fact
that Sanford had covered up
an extramarital affair
by claiming he'd been hiking
the Appalachian Trail.
Although, as we've noted before,
Trump kept getting
the name wrong.
-He was supposed to
be vacationing
on the Tallahassee Trail,
but he was actually
in Argentina.
I don't know --
Jim, do they have a
Tallahassee Trail in Argentina?
Never liked him too much.
I wasn't a big fan.
The Tallahassee Trail.
Must be a beautiful place.
Unfortunately,
he didn't go there.
-No, he didn't. Because...
It doesn't exist.
Tallahassee Trail sounds like
the patch of back hair
that leads down into your jorts.
[ Laughter ]
So the President
threatened the prosecutor
and the members of the jury
in his Senate impeachment trial,
and then we also found out
that he had seemingly threatened
the former ambassador
to Ukraine,
Marie Yovanovitch,
at a private dinner in 2018.
You might recall
that Yovanovitch
was a key witness in
the House impeachment hearing.
She was seen as a crusader
against corruption
and therefore an obstacle
to Trump and Rudy's corrupt plan
to get Ukraine to dig up dirt
on Joe Biden,
so Trump and Rudy
wanted her out.
And last week, a tape surfaced
in which Trump could be heard
talking about Yovanovitch
in menacing tones
with two of his
indicted henchmen,
Lev Parnas and Igor Fruman.
Do you remember these two guys?
If you have trouble remembering
who's who, Lev is the hot one.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you might remember that
Trump has repeatedly claimed
he doesn't know these two guys,
which is obviously a lie
given how often
Trump has had to say it.
-I don't know those gentlemen.
I don't know them.
I don't know about them.
I don't know what they do.
I will say this.
Parnas I don't know.
I don't know him.
I don't know anything about him.
Well, I don't know him.
I don't know Parnas.
I don't know him at all,
don't know what he's about.
Don't know where he comes from.
Know nothing about him.
I don't know him. I don't
believe I've ever spoken to him.
But I don't know him.
I've never had a conversation
that I remember with him.
I don't need the help of a man
that I never met before.
I don't even know
who this man is.
No, I don't know him.
I know nothing about him.
-When you have to say
you've never met someone
that many times,
you've definitely met
that person.
It's like if your wife asks,
"Do you know Julia next door?"
And you said, "I don't know her,
never talked to her.
Don't know who she is or where
she came from or what she does.
I've never spoken to her.
I've never m--
I've never had a conversation.
Who is she? Why are y--
I don't know her."
Your wife would have
her bags packed
before you finished talking.
Well, to no one's surprise,
it turns out Trump very much
did know these guys, and now
we have an audio recording
of Trump talking to Parnas
at a private dinner in 2018
that's in the hands
of federal authorities
in which they discuss
getting rid of Yovanovitch.
-ABC News has reviewed a
recording of what appears to be
a conversation between Parnas,
the President, and others.
A copy of the recording
is in the hands of the U.S.
Attorney's office in New York.
Sources familiar
with the recording say
it was made in April 2018
at a private dinner
at the Trump International Hotel
in Washington.
Parnas and the President
are heard discussing Ukraine
and the American ambassador
there, Marie Yovanovitch.
-How is it possible
that so many people
have secret recordings
of the President?
I mean, this idiot has had more
microphones and hidden cameras
on him than Jim Carrey
in "The Truman Show."
Michael Cohen had
secret recordings of Trump.
Omarosa had secret recordings
of Trump. And now this guy.
Trump was so worried
about Obama spying on him,
he failed to notice
that everyone else was.
This is why it's so crucial
that the Senate vote to allow
new evidence to be considered
in the impeachment trial
because almost every day
new evidence emerges.
In fact, just last night,
we got more bombshell reporting
about a tell-all book
being written by Trump's
former national-security
adviser, John Bolton.
You might remember that,
according to witnesses,
Bolton had wanted no part of
Trump and Rudy's Ukraine scheme,
calling it a "drug deal"
and saying Giuliani's
"a hand grenade who's going to
blow everybody up.'
Of course, if anything, Rudy
looks like he blew himself up.
That's how he lost his neck.
"Luckily they were able
to sew my head
right back onto my shoulders!"
Now it turns out that
in his forthcoming book
Bolton plans to lay out
in detail that Trump told him
explicitly
that he wanted to hold up
hundreds of millions of dollars
in aid to Ukraine in order to
force them to help him cheat
in the 2020 election.
-"The New York Times" reports
that former national-security
adviser John Bolton's
upcoming book
will say the President
personally tied aid to Ukraine
to an investigation
of the Bidens.
-It's insane.
Every day, someone new
comes forward with more evidence
against Trump.
Gordon Sondland,
Lev Parnas, John Bolton.
Tomorrow, the pilot
on Air Force One
is going to come forward
and be like, "The President
ordered me to illegally park
in a handicapped spot."
The president and his cabal
of thuggish goons
have threatened everyone
from ambassadors
to members of Congress
as new evidence emerges
every day of his crimes.
And Republicans
are feigning false outrage
at an innocuous comment
by Adam Schiff
just to distract
from the actual case.
If Trump had any shame at all,
he'd resign and disappear
someplace no one could find him
like...
-The Tallahassee Trail.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]